el regreso de bachar al azar a la escena
internacional está a la vista el consejo
de cooperación del Golfo llamó a una
reunión para discutir la posibilidad del
retorno de Siria a la liga árabe en jeda
en Arabia Saudita los ministros de
relaciones exteriores de Egipto Irak y
Jordania se enfrentan cara a cara al
jefe de la diplomacia Siria faisal quien
se encuentra en el reino en la primera
visita de este tipo desde el comienzo de
la guerra civil de su país en 2011 Siria
estuvo aislado diplomáticamente desde
que un levantamiento popular desencadenó
una guerra hace 12 años tras la
represión del régimen sirio pero desde
el terremoto del 6 de febrero que
devastó una gran parte del territorio al
azar ha buscado ayuda y distintos
acercamientos con países de la región
como oman Egipto e Irán estamos muy
contentos de que los países de la región
se hayan vuelto realistas y hayan
adoptado posiciones realistas con
respecto al papel de Siria y las
importantes posiciones que ocupa
en 2011 pocos meses después del
estallido de la guerra la liga árabe
expulsó a Siria luego de imponer
sanciones económicas y políticas al
considerar que al azar no respetó el cc
al fuego acordado en un plan de paz
establecido por la liga que fue aceptado
por Damasco pero ahora los aliados
podrían invitar al presidente sirio a la
Cumbre anual que está prevista para el
19 de mayo la liga árabe nació en 1945
con el objetivo de unir a los Estados
miembros de oriente próximo y el magret
y cooperar en materia cultural religiosa
y económica con las recientes alianzas
militares para atender a la guerra en
yemen y el avance del estado islámico la
liga tiene un componente militar también
aunque está dividida entre los países
que apoyan las políticas de Estados
Unidos y los que